je voudrais saluer tous les français qui
nous regardaient leur dire s'ils sont de
droite qu'ils vont devoir ce soir est un
peu courageux et et patient puisque
l'inégalité des temps de parole va
conduire les quatre candidats d'extrême
gauche à près de 45 minutes de temps de
parole alors non non non j'ai rappelé
l'arrière des noms d'accord maaf à vous
de voir je le vois bien plus des lotois
exprime monde et on est interrompue mais
il n'empêche la réalité suffit
d'additionner les tentes par les quatre
candidats d'extrême gauche weeds
cumuleront 45 minutes de temps la
députée faut garder voilà ce qui arrive
quand on ne respecte pas les règles ce
sont des images d'un an l'indonésie
invisible qui a sauté de la clôture pour
se prendre en photo avec un orang outan
enfin alors il en daim fait les frères
l'arête sur l'animal regarder
il la grille et ne le lâche plus bel et
bien de ce genre de bonne qualité
[Musique]
nous appliquons absolument est
strictement les règles the hill sont
l'as rome qui nous impose sur les temps
de parole de les vendre en compte c'est
bien dans le jeu gilles eboli parole des
éliminatoires unis dans les
circonscriptions il statuera étonnant
monsieur monsieur pelletier ya juste
choses là c'est la loi qui nous y
autorise et donc c'est
obligés nous y oblige pardon est une loi
il est établi peut-être prenez c'est
donc la future majorité qui décidera ou
pas d'amender cette loi dans un afin à
vos côtés messieurs un homme de radio et
télévision aussi un écrivain passionné
cyril hanouna
non aux quêteurs enquêteuse personne
chargée d'une enquête voilà c'est tout
ouais tu t'excuses s'excuser de quoi
j'ai dit les deux camps s'accusent
face
à cette menace
s
excuse toi
le haut qualifie une personne est que
ces crabes et antipathique odieuse oui
un trou de mémoire personne n'avait vu
ça c'est l'image qui intrigue depuis
lundi soir à la fin du match de ligue
des nations autriche danemark les
joueurs danois se sont plaints d'un gros
creux de 30 centimètres dans la pelouse
du stade de vienne qui aurait pu causer
de graves blessures
selon les experts ce problème serait dû
aux pluies diluviennes de ces derniers
jours pas de quoi rassurer avant la
rencontre autriche-france demain mais le
terrain est en phase de consolidation et
la rencontre maintenu par les autorités
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ici toujours un plaisir pour moi tu sais
d'ouvrir à nice
[Musique]
j'espère tu as bien manger mon nico qui
je jouais bien
mais c'est l'occasion de te dire ma
reconnaissance profond mon amitié
sincère pour la finale
ces grosses un pâté
mais toujours vide on peut voir la pure
ensemble on peut on peut j'ai un pote
qui s'appelle bruno basse que la halakha
nom de famille qui s'appelle ricard
c'est vrai jean luc et en plus javi de
rue de l'abreuvoir
cette émission alors la perfection haute
de soutenir
tellement soutenu que m'a tellement
aidée je fais bon courage et bonne
chance pour dimanche
hubert billysiens négo
[Rires]
fait en réalité on va dire la vérité on
était obligés par la loi d'invités
quatre représentants de la nuque puisque
la nuque est un est une alliance jeunes
qui à cinq semaines et avant vous étiez
chacun dans vampire gloire donc vous
aviez entendent parole vous avez chacun
du temps de parole c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre que même je veux dire la
vérité même nous on a eu du mal à
comprendre qu'on va dire on va dire que
ce soit
ce sont les mêmes
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi vous
avez buggé là pourquoi oui ça on a
compris je peux dire sans cent mille
fois parce que jusqu'à ce que l'univers
me répondent les boules des bretons
[Musique]
non les boules les bretons c'est pas
votre truc non d'accord que bon on verra
dans quel boulot sujet on continue asus
il en a deux ah bah tiens dans la
culotte
[Musique]
tony le thé c'est noté ça n'a rien à
voir avec notre but d'avant